قالت هيئه الاركان العامه الاوكرانيه ان
القوات الاوكرانيه افشلت هجمات للقوات
الروسيه في ضواحي باخمه الشماليه
في بيانها ان سته واربعين اشتباكا وقعت مع
القوات الروسيه في مقاطعه
بمقاطعه خارجي كما اشارت هيئه الاركان الى
ان القوات الروسيه تنفذت اكثر من اربعين
غاره وعشرات الضربات الصاروخيه واستخدمت
مسارات في هجماتها شرقي البلاد
وفي خلصنا فضل حاكم الاوكراني للمدينه
بمقتل سته مدريين واصابه اخرين في قصف
روسي المتواصل على هذه المقاطعه وقال ان
القوات الروسيه قصفت المقاطعتها اكثر من
80 مره خلال الساعات الماضيه واطلقت قرابه
400 قذيفه على المناطق الماهوله بالسكان
وشبكات البنيه التحتيه وفي المجاوره اعلن
عمده المقاطعه وقوع اصابات في صفوف
المدنيين جراء استمرار القصف الروسي على
المواقع الساحليه لسيمه في اوتشكا